ran ran
あああっナマダダダダランばから夏
だなら the rooms were 石鹸100個買いました後切れずねまず開け
ますわ
よしてきました今日は遠くたーーーー始めたはいこそように見えますさあ見ての草履
石鹸100個でございます
最高いう訳でございますかうって言ってございます
をやばいベルマークついてんじゃんってが車くっついてるあ0.5ペン通いたて
シンプルな設計を100個買ったんですけどもうなんかねー
ネットの情報なんですけどてがもう動画を何個かあるんですけど
石鹸をレッスン時にれるとなんかすごいことになるみたいなのあったわけなんです
8 pro 3の1個で試してみようと思いますまず1個で何が起きないが水
以下で何が起きるかというのも人に見せたいですよ行く際
[音楽]
予習しきたぞ僕は初めてよねー
ちょっと何を言ってるかわかんないんですよ
まあ石鹸を無駄にするなっていう意見もあるかもしれないですけど僕も絶叫のつもりで
やってるって
実験人犠牲はつきものですライト兄弟といろんなことを犠牲にして辿り着いたんです
僕も
[音楽]
僕もん
有名な科学者に臨みて
多少の犠牲は必要だと思っています
おっ
なんか怖い手前染まったのタコはルーン勝てないぞみなきゃねば勝つとかじゃないよね
ちょっと当たった麺とか[ __ ]欠かせないよだめ箱付では持ってきてね大丈夫
詰まってえっちょっていい匂いする
ぐうっちょっとってえっ大丈夫でね
矢部見えるかなぁ大丈夫か+ゲインっ
なんかねベースレンジに挙げると高原でちょっとね大気になるんですよこういう感じで
なんかすごいすっクラーン際わけでございますそれぞれ考えてもらって横の音設計をね
まぁ百個一気に米戦で打ち込むともう1台かするわけじゃないですかきゃんこいッきり
この電子レンジで設定を打ち込んでえっするとひょっとしたら新たな可能性が生まれる
かもしれない俺はその可能性
いや何か分からないんだおそらく石鹸を100個絶縁中二病としてとこういうふうには
そんなにいないた俺はその可能性に賭けたいと思ってるたとえ何が起きようとも俺は
それを受け止めるこの世界の未来を科学にあるなぁ2人を
the stack もいっぱい球技でまずは本当にキャットあるか数えてみましょう
実験には正確な数値が必要なんだよねどうぞやっぱり失敗したらだめよです
[音楽]
本当にでも若干っていうか数えないとわからないですけど
例えてみましょう10個の縦列で中かける中で100個ありますまあさっき見てもらっ
た通り
設計の電池出るとちょっと坊主を謳歌するんですバキュラてに大きさが違うんです
100校混ぜ瞬時に入れてみて前例が坊主はすると
2月100個入れて膨張するとどうなるかというのは実際に見てみようと思います皆
石鹸100個なんてそう簡単に見れるもんだねはいスクショタイムです今のうちに
screenshot してください
言い換え
ok それだ
[拍手]
voodoo
dare
サーバー群
ません
もう全35市で動いてるパワー設計した
スポッ
最初から構成作家んだどうなるんでしょうね
ひゃっ広域に膨張するととても怖いですね
お母さん
こんなことしてごめんなさいいただきましょうチーツー
fire
ああああああん
どうなる最初はまだそんなこなさそういやでバーガーずさあ強い感があったかもしれ
ません
今のところ問題なしですただここからどうなるかは悩むな子はホント怖いん
[音楽]
爆発したら本当にありがたいと思ってしまってまだ変化はないですねなんか
期ぶりでてねっ
7けむり家てなんか上記でてね染まったこれやばくね
ああやっ大丈夫
アジア7季ぶりが燃料101または
明らかに煙が出てるんだけどちょっとも山でも試しもよろしくお願いし
も試してもうダメですもうダメっす
ええええええ
[音楽]
って
ん
うわぁ web
[音楽]
ジェニー f
中にすっごい焦げた部分もあります
んパパ